do you know this person no I see I do  know who that is  Jalen rinsed my question is do you guys  look like I want to know what you think  chin here there's definitely some  similarities  so you're just blind to it who is this  but you almost said it was Jonas he  almost said Travis Kelce was Jonas but  this is uncanny  that is kind of weird are there any  differences one cry speak really good  English what doesn't you have to see  this - nah no first off you thought that  it was Jonas you thought it was Jonas  and now traffic background what do we  think of this that is it Herod bad here  that's a good grade that's a bad grade I  think Jenny he means uh Danny needs a  little something there mr. Jesse  something Carl twins  Danny ate with Danny put your foot Danny  yes so now they all look alike  I love getting y'all look alike I'm  sorry this is just like last Jalen and  Kyle photo I'll show I just I'm just no  I'm not even close no seriously not even  close